hasta el momento hemos estado haciendo
problemas en donde yo prácticamente he
inventado todos los valores y todo ha
resultado muy sencillo de calcular pero
ahora encontré un problema en internet y
pienso que será interesante porque los
números no son tan sencillos bueno no
tanto como el seno y el coseno de 30
grados ahora el ángulo será de 35 grados
y solo para asegurarme de que
obtendremos la misma solución que los
que subió en ese problema en internet
vamos a usar la aceleración de la
gravedad en
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado en
lugar de los 10 que veníamos usando como
aproximación de la aceleración de la
gravedad vamos a usar la real
vayamos al problema tenemos esta rampa
que tiene encima una masa de 10
kilogramos y está conectada mediante
este cable que no tiene nada de masa a
otro peso
de 20 kilogramos este cable está encima
pasando por encima de una polea que
permite que esto se mueva sin fricción
bueno qué va a pasar
en este sistema
bueno
simplemente viendo sabemos que bueno
esta masa de 20 kilogramos tendrá o
bueno tiene toda la fuerza de la
gravedad no hay nada que impida que vaya
hacia abajo excepto lo que está cargando
este cable
y bueno tenemos que está pasando está
conectando esta persona por encima está
la polea el cable y lo conecta a esta
masa que es menor de 10 kilogramos y
esta masa se encuentra sobre esta rampa
entonces bueno
tenemos que está más sabe también tener
su inercia va a estar el componente de
la gravedad y este su componente de
gravedad paralelo a la superficie va a
estar intentando que esta masa se vaya
hacia aquí hacia abajo a la izquierda y
también tenemos la fricción entre esta
masa y esa superficie que esto que está
en contra del movimiento nosotros
intuitivamente vemos que esto al ser
mayor pues va a jalar todo este sistema
hacia la derecha pero bueno con qué tan
que tan rápido lo va a jalar que depende
de la componente de gravedad de esta
masa paralela a la superficie y la
fricción que tengamos
esto todo esto lo vamos a calcular más
adelante
bueno entonces ya vimos que todo esto va
a estarse moviendo hacia la derecha
ahora vamos a calcular los valores
entonces el objeto de 20 kilogramos se
va a acelerar hacia abajo más lento de
lo que sería si no estuviera conectado a
todo este mecanismo
que los está jalando hacia atrás un poco
el problema nos dice que el coeficiente
de fricción entre la masa de 10
kilogramos y la rampa vamos a notar los
datos el coeficiente de flexión muy
entre estos dos elementos es igual a 0.2
veamos el conjunto de fuerzas que actúan
en este objeto bueno está la fuerza de
gravedad la perpendicular al plano
y que volvamos a ponerle otras etiquetas
vamos a dibujar también los vectores
entonces tenemos
nuestro vector
de la fuerza de gravedad que va hacia
abajo
tenemos este vector y lo que captamos
como eje de fuerza de gravedad
tenemos nuestra fuerza paralela
perdón perpendicular a la superficie de
dios bueno
es imagínense un vector más derecho pero
este vector
y vamos a llamarlo efe
psd perpendicular a la superficie
y tenemos otro vector
que este es el vector que es paralelo
a la superficie
este vector es para el el oeste entonces
le ponemos fp de paralelo
ok y además tenemos nuestra fuerza
normal que tiene la misma magnitud que
esta fuerza para perpendicular a la
superficie pero va en sentido contrario
entonces la normal la fuerza normal va
hacia acá
y este es f m
bueno entonces tenemos aquí ubicados
nuestros vectores o las fuerzas que van
está trabajando en este objeto de los
vídeos anteriores recordemos que el
ángulo este ángulo va a ser el mismo
ángulo que el que tenemos aquí si tienen
dudas les recomiendo que regresen a ver
los vídeos anteriores
sobre masas en un plano inclinado para
que puedan ver la demostración de por
qué estos ángulos son iguales entonces
tenemos aquí el ángulo de 35 grados
y ahora queremos calcular la fuerza
perpendicular está fps
bueno recordemos para eso tenemos que
calcular primero nuestra fuerza de
gravedad que va a ser nuestra hipotenusa
en este sistema
entonces
nuestra fuerza de gravedad
es igual a la masa por la aceleración
que nuestra masa es de 10 kilogramos y
la aceleración es de 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado que nos da una
fuerza de
98 minutos
también siendo les vimos que agua lo que
les comentaba de este ángulo entonces
ahora sí quiero calcular este vector que
es el cateto adyacente al ángulo entre
la hipotenusa pues voy a usar la función
digo no métrica cocina con este ángulo
de 35 grados entonces mi fuerza
perpendicular a la superficie es igual a
la fuerza de gravedad
por el coseno de 35 grados que es igual
al 98 por el coseno de 35 y ya tengo los
cálculos bueno ya tengo calculado de
cocción de 35 grados y x 98 esto es
aproximadamente igual a 80 newtons si
quieren pagan pausa en el vídeo y hagan
este cálculo ustedes para que vean que
estos resultados son los correctos
entonces el componente de la gravedad
que jala hacia abajo perpendicular a la
superficie dentro de la rampa es de 80
minutos vamos a ir poniendo también los
valores aquí
fps es igual a 80
la fuerza de gravedad es igual al 98
newtons
y bueno ya que vimos que la fuerza
normal es exactamente la misma magnitud
que la fuerza perpendicular a la
superficie pero en sentido contrario
pues tenemos entonces que esta fuerza
normal va a ser igual también a 80
minutos
y bueno qué más nos hace falta calcular
la fuerza de fricción que vamos a llamar
nuestra fuerza de fricción efe
la fuerza de fricción va a estar en
sentido contrario al movimiento en
general mi fuerza de fricción que le
pongo efe subíndice f y esta fuerza de
fricción vimos en vídeos anteriores que
es igual al
al coeficiente de fricción por la fuerza
normal
y ya tenemos la fuerza normal entonces
tenemos que 0.2 por la fuerza normal que
sigue la magnitud es igual a la fuerza
perpendicular a la superficie que es 80
newtons entonces tenemos que son nos
quedan 16 newtons como fuerza de
fricción la fuerza de fricción va a
estar a este lado y es igual a 16
minutos
ok qué más
bueno ahora nos falta calcular la fuerza
paralela a la superficie y ahora
usaremos la fórmula trigonométricas que
involucra al seno ya que tenemos el
cateto opuesto
entonces me fuerza dependí cular perdón
paralela paralela a la superficie es
igual a mi fuerza de gravedad por el
seno de 35 grados
y esto es igual a la fuerza de gravedad
80 newtons por el seno de 35 grados y ya
he hecho los cálculos previos y esta
fuerza paralela
resulta ser de 56 minutos entonces la
fuerza paralela bueno es en este sentido
56 newtons pero también la puedo dibujar
aquí ya que bueno el movimiento va hacia
acá puedo dibujar el vector acá o acá
pero para que se note un poquito más
claro la fuerza que aparte es más grande
la fuerza paralela que la fuerza de
fricción entonces la fuerza paralela es
igual a 56 minutos
bueno vamos a ver a calcular la fuerza
neta en toda esta al menos en esta parte
del problema vamos a sumar ambas fuerzas
está la fuerza paralela y la fuerza neta
perdón la fuerza
de fricción y tengo que mi fuerza total
hacia la
izquierda hacia abajo a la izquierda es
56 + 16 es igual a 72 minutos
y bueno entonces ahora lo que necesito
calcular es bueno cuál va a ser la
fuerza que me va a estar jalando hacia
acá está este sentido
bueno entonces el peso del objeto
tenemos que es de 20 bueno vamos a
calcular el peso tenemos que la masa es
de 20 kilogramos entonces está mi fuerza
de gravedad aquí
ay dios
perdón con el dibujo de los vectores
pero
es medio difícil dibujar bien las líneas
rectas a mano pero mi fuerza de gravedad
aquí
es igual a la masa 20 kilogramos por la
aceleración de 9.8 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado
hacia abajo y esta multiplicación es
igual a 196 minutos entonces esto es
igual a 196 newtons hacia abajo
ok entonces ahora sí veamos la fuerza
neta de todo el sistema
tenemos 196 newtons hacia abajo que van
en este aplicándose a quien en esta masa
y tenemos 72 newtons que van hacia la
izquierda
en sentido contrario entonces cálculo mi
fuerza neta vamos a ponerla en otro
color
la fuerza neta y escribo la palabra
kinect a todo el sistema es igual a
196 minutos que van digamos hacia la
derecha y resto o quito los newtons que
van en sentido contrario que en este
caso son 72 newtons y tenemos 196 menos
72 igual a 124 newtons que van hacia la
derecha
y bueno esta es mi fuerza es la fuerza
de todo sistema que se está moviendo
hacia acá y ahora quiero saber cuál es
la aceleración bueno para calcular
aceleración necesitamos conocer la masa
de todo el sistema y pues la masa
involucra bueno la masa total involucra
estos dos objetos de 10 kilos y 20
kilogramos así que la masa total
la masa total es igual a la suma de
estos dos estados más 10 + 20 entonces
tenemos que es igual a 30 kilogramos
y así hacemos el cálculo de usando la
fórmula de fuerza igual a masa polar de
aceleración tenemos la fuerza neta del
sistema 124 es igual a la masa un 30 y
lo que queremos saber es la aceleración
del sistema no la diferente la
aceleración de la gravedad
entonces despejamos aceleración es igual
a 124
entre 30 y esto es igual
ya ha hecho todos mis cálculos previos
4.13 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
así que todo este sistema se va a
acelerar hacia la derecha a 4.13 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo